run it Steve okay ladies and gentlemen
welcome to your favorite podcast you
know today I got my hand in this thing
it might go over to Rick laughs whatever
here we go
[Music]
what I didn't like the way I did I feel
like you're still a gentleman all right
here we go
[Music]
that'll do yeah I think we got it
oh [ __ ] people write you a lot how much
they love your theme song yeah you get
that a lot yeah those guys are great
they're called the octave cat and dopa
pod I saw David the band yeah they
should change all of those names
it's a weird but they're great dudes
detect you let me know them detective
design I can't I can't listen to these
headphones with it with your with your
[Music]
so many wires here it looks like I don't
have a punch line yet nobody needs to
know the underbelly of what's going on
all right what do you guys think do you
want to know the underbelly don't
unleash some comments down below and let
us know if you want to see the four I'll
just edit this out
just take that phone's off you don't
need them yeah you'll need them for the
music anyway so now we're ready to go
okay I said poof pop surprised and
panicked yeah all right
lead it when I'm on my podcast I have to
like the under seat my wires is mine the
underbelly of your podcast is like every
two seconds Rick is doing like this and
then he's talking to his editor okay I
just went right now I want you to bring
some pyrotechnics in and then like raise
me up bring me down zoom into my
forehead okay boom and then we're back
half these things and I'm always giving
notes to the editor right so when I'm
watching this I'm like all right when I
step make sure you flip me flip me not
360 written like a mirror so my right
eye is my left eye and I'm watching it
like Perry's got to be so [ __ ]
annoyed with me my 90 minute podcasts
are two and a half hours because of all
the direction but I'll tell you
something and you'll be the first to
admit it no podcasts is as beautiful and
well-executed and hilarious and
insightful and amazing as take your
shoes off you get my merchants Rick
Glassman calm you're a nightmare take
the lead I don't have it today you know
yeah what's going on with you today
something's going on tell me what's
going on I'll tell you exactly what's
going on I'll tell you when when it
started when did this start when I got
in the car to come
here why I don't know if subconsciously
I'm terrified of you Oh Mike or if is
there something in my car but I'm
leaning toward the former I'm in the
best mood I you know I'll tell you what
I did this morning I had sex okay
okay but there CMI there's three
visionary doggy
reverse cowgirl I've never done anything
about missionary is she on top you on
[Laughter]
top might as well do yoga there's three
types of there's there's there's sex
love and [ __ ] we can all agree right
is there a fourth one that I'm missing
sex love and [ __ ] okay right
I guess usually I experience making love
or [ __ ] right it's like this is
connected kissing eye contact or just
like oh you know vagina you betcha
I had sex this morning okay and I don't
have sex that much it almost felt like
and I don't mean this as an insult to
you Betty I mean this just as a this is
what it is
I love the assumption that Betty is
watching my podcast I like that we my
friends and family love this show I told
you this I said it on my no cut to a
clip and we won't I know we won't but it
was one of the your yours and Dec
Shepherds podcast is when I started
listening to podcasts and why I not know
why I'm making one but anyway it felt
like a utility just felt like yeah I
think I need to come but let me ask you
something when you're having sex is it
always just for you no okay then who
initiated this sex she left the room
mm-hm and because I'm gonna like sleep a
little bit more and I had a I might lie
to say boner on your podcast
yeah okay but you still hear boner
underneath
Naboo do the boo I had a boner and a
boner
I had a boo the key feels sketchy about
where people's names are farts have you
ever seen that dude I mean like if I was
like welcome to the prospect cast mr.
[Music]
holy show a clip no I don't want one
I might actually it's a good idea I
think you know it because of you I've
been inspired calling inspiration I'm
saying it's stealing my what makes me
special and I see that it's actually not
that special because it's pretty easy
okay you know when you throw a little
picture in at minute 20 Shore but when
you have images every 15 seconds and
they're doing fun flips come on nobody
could do a fun flip push from the left
and spin from the bottom but yes so sure
you had the boner she left her room I
had a boob she left and I was just kind
of like you know my hand was around the
area respectfully your area I'll never
touch my boob without consent I'll tell
you that right oh my god and I literally
went Betty and I and I said I asked her
I asked her will she as if she's doing
me a favor
she was well you know you know you
scratch my back and uh suck my boob and
no no I don't want to make this as blue
as it's become yeah it was just like
yeah and and it's not really how I
normally am but a silly mood and we're
talking booze you know but yeah I had
sex this morning and it just it was like
okay here we go yeah yeah I don't mean
to cut you off but I'm gonna let you do
and that's okay no no but I just want to
like say something that so you could
continue your story with this thought in
your head yeah maybe what you consider
sex in there is like like I always say
sometimes you know sex is like
lovemaking or [ __ ] like you're saying
but or it's assisted masturbation mhm
you know that's exactly what this
I wanted to give you this so in that
moment you're like oh because you just
you had someone to help you
yeah when after oh I mean it was still
like loafers connected and it's great
but it's light enough to always help
don't say that for her benefit oh it
really is equal time you're connected I
can't be hard if I'm not connected I
know I know actually I understand what
you're saying
yeah so yes but is it the most connected
or was it some assisted masturbation
yeah it was assisted masturbation it was
thank you for the third hand yeah what
you used to all the time you don't have
to know you don't have your one move oh
I can't I can't I can't get an eye first
of all let's get real yeah that's all
you with you'll be able to be with any
one of your dick okay so then you why do
you feel bad that you had this I feel
bad no you said that that's when you
started to feel bad no no it's just I
was just walking you through the day
okay so that's that's part of the day
then yes okay and that's not because the
sex was so great that's just because
this is can't even wear the headphones
because haven't figured out your wires
that is not what it is okay so defensive
yeah but we had sex and you know what it
was and this is - this is me being
self-deprecating not calling up Eddie I
had sex Ronnie just well yes sure yeah
because when you go your plugs in so
when she sir whispering to me like you
know she was be tight you know yes so so
basically if we were talking to Betty
right now she's on a podcast going I had
the worst sex Betty she loves me so much
no see you see get on the phone yeah get
her on the phone and I want to ask her
if this was the best sex you've had
today you know was the best sex she I
mean I hope it's the fact that she had
today
oh that's sure you know we actually I
don't know it might mess up the
microphone but you can like well she's
in yoga right now oh she needed to get
some exercise in after that [ __ ]
train wreck
no no no everything is fine we had sex
and then I got up I showered and I came
over here and then I got in the car I
was just like I don't feel good yeah
what's the new year are you are you are
y'all so good are you happy with where
you are right now and then starting to
2020 you know nice question yeah that's
it
no fault will follow through oh you know
my all all I do is the podcast yeah it's
all I do
well cuz the way you do it it could only
be all that you do and that's why you
have to have sex like this cut to
splooge on her face do you earn
swordfish when Hugh Jackman is is there
there testing how good of a hacker he is
whoa whoa whoa you're making a swordfish
reference we'll put a black that's in
everybody's lexicon that's why you
reference it and your IG story you just
put it on top okay for those of you
idiots who don't know what I'm talking
about by the way swordfish is the first
time Halle Berry ever went nude how
about that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he's getting a blood that he's has to
hack into something and to test how good
he is at hacking we're gonna put a gun
to your head and make somebody suck your
dick half before you come oh yeah I
remember that scene yeah that's a weird
reference can you set up as if like I'm
editing up in my computer yeah I know
but it's where did that popped into your
head that's the only time I've seen
someone get their dick sucked while
editing that was in your rolodex I get
the hole they're like you were going
swordfish all there man really that's
why whenever we're doing stuff and you
talk about how I'm always thinking about
what edits to make I'm thinking about Oh
Eric is wearing a shirt that I saw in
the second season of Breaking Bad we
could put on yeah alright so you're not
I remember when you first started doing
it and you would
these edits I remember saying like okay
man it won't let see how it goes I by
episode 20 you know but you're you're
still going strong and then you actually
got helpers and you're like yeah I've
been getting people helping me out shout
out to Perry groan - George Creek as'
and my new buddy Pepe but you came on I
did eight for the holiday special yeah I
did I get my trick thank you you're
welcome
that is a do people know you as mr.
Potato Head or is that like yeah that's
something Bobby always says you just say
that's him yeah you didn't know that did
you're not original
oh I'm original watch this well cut to a
clip just put me upside down and I did
eight episodes in eight eight nights and
the editing was it was 12 hours a day
yeah it was like I could do anything I
uploaded one and then I did what you do
to premiere yeah so then I'm watching I
don't want to [ __ ] watch this I've
been watching this for 12 hours I'm
watching all I'm editing the next one
for eight days Betty got in she lives in
London she got in on December 23rd for
the first five days she's there I'm just
editing I felt so bad yeah it's a lot
yeah so now I'm back to what do we force
you to go to a clipper game right yeah
it wasn't just a clipper game was
clipper rockets yeah and you're all like
I know so I have been resenting it a
little bit but then I'm just so happy
with it I'm just so happy with how I can
tell I can tell but I don't you have
time for anything else I mean are you
watching movie shows like what like what
do you do for like so this nights they
work now this eight nights took up for
three weeks it was everything of my all
my time and I in that I've implemented
this new engine where but this is boring
who gives a [ __ ] about this right is
this interesting your I find it very
interesting during this time I needed
help no cuz I'm gonna do an edit and
it's gonna be me in a bit right so we'll
do a pickup [ __ ] you before making that
sleep that let's do a quick pickup no
we're not gonna go during that time I
found new ways of executing this and and
not focusing too much on too many things
and now that I'm out of the weeds and
I'm back to doing one a week I feel like
I've gotten better at this because I had
to well yeah
actually once you have once you're doing
eight in a week when you're just doing
one you're like yeah it's like it's like
Goku goes in extra gravity and comes
back to earth
there you go to Starbucks and you want
to edit their security footage yeah I
have ideas I show this gown and the
scone is good so yeah so my hours were
like 20 to 40 hours what are you doing
for fun this time trying to get to Rick
yes so now what are you what cuz I don't
even know like what are you into the
whole ER you always watch watch TV shows
or movies like what TV shows are you
watching um I'm just now starting a
third season miss basil oh you know what
I'm watching which is show that I is I
don't know if I like it but I cannot
wait for Friday to get the new one
serviced I was just talking I know that
is you know I have no idea what the [ __ ]
is going on on that show like I don't
know if it's a psychological thriller or
if there or there's gonna be magic at
some point huh you know what I mean and
it's just like this laughter you see the
last episode man I can't [ __ ] Betty's
like Betty's like I I don't like this I
don't want to watch this show anymore
and she went to bed I watched an episode
I came back I told what happened she's
like yeah I don't want to watch it I
said well I'm not to watch another one
do you she's like yeah and if you watch
it she needs to watch the next I thought
the first episode was weird because it
like a character in the show are these
weird camera angles you know what I mean
I feel like it's a character you know
because sometimes I do like let's say
we're talking like this you know they're
shooting like this though the shooting
past my nose and again you close above
you in a sight oh this is a weird choice
and I think it was like like the
cinematographer whoever they sat down
and were like alright this is gonna be
part of the show so you get all these
weird I think they made some mistakes
and you think it was bad I mean but that
does that's the one that my shaman
himself directed he hasn't directed any
others I don't think the first one yeah
so I don't know how much he's a part of
all the other ones but it's a very
bizarre show they've really did a good
job of needing us to see one more yeah
what like just last episode the last one
I was like was that the one with the dog
the last one no
no the last one is the one you haven't
seen though yes okay I said one word
they know if you haven't then the doll
never dolls back yeah yeah and Rupert
Grint is like at the end the baby's
there and you're like what happened I
have I think I know and I know that I
understand that she obviously wanted to
know what's really going on then why is
the earth what's the what's the devil
coming up from the basement with the
cracks yeah stuff okay so we're back
with an advertisement from Marshall Roy
gallery it's my dad's drugstore I
putting in all my episodes
your dad's rug store and it's been going
in my podcast and Jeremiah's now I cut
to it and I footing it huh oh my god
just send it I love your dad snap and
we're back that's my thing don't get
used to it
what do you talk I'm doing solo episodes
I'm stealing from Chris D'Elia you
stealing from him I'm doing solo
episodes I'm doing like but now I'm
using clips so it's not really I'm not
really stealing your thing cuz your
thing is just like edits for no reason
you know I mean which it was the working
title of your podcast for no reason I
would say it would be like okay Swiss
cheese candles they work let me let me
show you there's a way of making them
work where they're silly but they serve
a purpose let me give you an example
okay yeah this new merch and you get
it's a good way of showing like I don't
wanna have to say go to Rick Glassman
calm pick up a hoodie I don't want
people to know I don't want you have to
put up right here Rick Glassman calm
slash store or whatever the [ __ ] it
would be but first Marshalls rug store
Oh
Marshalls rug gallery okay alright
there's also something about the snap
bit that gets me like literally I get a
little dopamine hit I've seen a little
bit of a bit oh no no that's funny you
say that cuz I when I'm on your podcast
and I'm looking at you your brain fires
at that moment cuz you're already like
okay I know what we need to do I need to
do this and everything's like watch this
just give me a snap that's comedy baby
it's call but it's easy I just I don't
appreciate it you brought another
[ __ ] mustache to my podcast I bring
them everywhere no no you brought a
[ __ ] one with you oh yeah because I
bring my muscles everywhere by sometimes
normally I have to go I have to go pick
up mustache actually want to get
sponsored by Hollywood toy in costume
the amount of money I'm spending on
stashes but anyways the servant is good
I'm glad you're watching that your thing
we still go back to the servant yeah
are you watching any did you ever did
you ever get to see on the on Apple TV
it's the other one the one with Jason
Momoa or and I always call him Jason
mimosa you don't seem that one no
everybody's blind it's like 500 years in
the future well that's another one of
these crazy Apple TV shows morning show
I finished I'm not even gonna watch down
it's only you and like 1500 people that
are watching that show it's more people
than you got in here that's not true on
the premiere at this moment everyone can
everyone right now by the way if you're
watching and you haven't given it a
thumbs up yet we're not even at a
hundred lights make it seem like it's
live he's always like or 96 come on come
on if you don't put that out there
oh let's not put out four thumbs down
yeah this podcast doesn't have four
thumbs down by now I'm not coming back
Oh who says you're gonna be back you
stop before you when you said you wanna
get me I know they cut to me saying that
usually you are I can see you gonna
eventually have you gonna be kind of
person's gonna have your own show
like Tracey Ullman or something like
that right and I'm I'm pretty sure it's
gonna be good it'll be fascinating you
no but you're gonna be a nightmare to
work for okay yes you're gonna be a
monster but that's gonna bring the best
out of the product because your your
energy about like what to do on the
podcast and all that stuff is just like
no behind the scenes I'm a bi show at
the end like all the outtakes will be a
view like here's what's cool about a
podcast for the person making the
podcast it's easy you want to do
stand-up
you got to travel the country you got to
master your set you've got a mink mingle
you got to deal with your agents and
blah blah blah and that's great and I'm
grateful for it it's a fun time but it's
a lot of work this is easy why not just
put in a little bit of work into the
podcast we're putting something out
there just because it's an easy all we
need you don't worry first of all I put
in more than a little bit I'm insulted
because you think that I just put a
little bit of work into doing all this
what else you think this is a little bit
of work I'm saying I'm saying cutting to
me [ __ ] in the bushes isn't that
much work and it's a guaranteed laugh
you don't believe me guys tell me if
this works
234 like 238 like somebody got rid of
one of the thumbs down yelling peace I
can't wear my headphones because you're
a lot of work my god you're just a
nightmare I was in your premiere for
your episodes yesterday doing bits like
this yeah even in that you texted me and
you said knock it off put you on timeout
for a second sometimes you get put
people on timeout I say what you texted
me why you techno right okay if you want
to find out hop on over to take this
shoes off and I'll reveal the real
behind the scenes or you could just
click right here
you know what I people are gonna be
annoyed by me I could tell oh you think
yeah yeah my god dude anyways I'm gonna
tone it down and you guys are about to
be less annoyed but it's also gonna get
boring Oh impossible watch no Rikyu
cuz milk is right now people gonna be
fascinated that Rick Glassman is calm
for like what how long is it you can
pull that off a couple minutes I know
but you know what tickles me you being
annoyed that I won't do it I don't know
it that you won't do it this is your
podcast you take over every podcast you
go on I can't wait til you get to do
like Joe Rogan or something and I want
to see you yeah okay Joe just hear me
out
whatever it is we can do it at the end
you do it now I told you know what's
hilarious you actually could do this
edit cuz you know how Joe does it like
you know they cut you just you just add
yourself to one of his podcasts and just
do this [ __ ] in the bush we'll be right
back with another word from Marshall rut
gallery which is exactly what Marshall
Rock is doing with their prices right
now I wanna I'm gonna have Chris Delia's
dad on Bill D'Elia sure so I should
probably get your dad on he would be
great
have you seen my dad has come out a few
of yeah yeah yeah get super high he's a
great guest I know and put the but I'll
probably be like my Benz C word episode
where people are just like you know I
got a message on one of my words I have
a sticker over here someplace
been bought one of my shirts and
somebody commented saying that they
bought a shirt because they saw Ben post
about it
so shout out to Ben c-word forgetting my
merch out there which in if you don't
know where that is it's just right here
you get it
I gave you a shirt for eight nights a
tie so do you still have it yeah it's
someplace cut to me looking for it yeah
WOB in the bushes shitty what Rick wears
you down I know I said it too like I
person that would break into your house
to edit this [ __ ] you know and then
you'd be pissed
yeah cut to us in court yeah then you're
trying to explain to the judge and
you're like look judge let me show you
with the Edit what do you mean I go let
me rephrase I'm in a suit what is he
showing for me for making this podcast
better trimming out the fat and cutting
to the and then the bailiff goes urine
handcuffs so right now I show a scene
from Night Court
yeah but then you won't be able to make
the money oh no I had bill lawrence on
who is he was my old boss he created the
show I was on undateable he created
scrubs and a whole bunch of shows he's a
big big show runner and his daughter is
Charlotte Lawrence who is is this new
pop star and she's very successful right
here see her here oh you put in a
picture I thought you're saying she's
sitting in the chair now I'm gonna put a
picture I was gonna snap and ever come
here and sit in the truck I love this
deffence and Bill wanted me to put in
one of her songs right for a moment cry
and I said yeah I mean I'd be happy to
but once we put in her music is it I
don't get any of the money yeah I'm
making you know X dollars per episode
you give me the money I put it the song
he says fine so now I'm gonna crossroads
where it's like okay but do I really ask
the guy who gave me a career for you
know a couple hundred bucks tops yeah I
put it is so then I was thinking I might
want to ask her to sing me something
just put her picture up and just sing
the song what will you do it I don't
know her songs
and why should I do it can you wait
trying to ruin my ad money experiences
if you sing it now we're in my that's
[ __ ] brilliant let's say we're my
house right now here we are like you
some matrix you know say that all the
all the guns just came or something and
then but I don't know I don't know if I
really want to do all that though dude
come on
so what we got to drive to your place
today if you're over will put it in I'll
remember I have I have notes of all the
pickup's know what we're gonna have to
do is this is gonna have to be like
we're gonna have to plan it out we're
gonna have to storyboard our crossover
episode it writes itself
no but come on to do it right truthfully
I hear you and I understand the value in
that but the way that pod for me and I
believe you podcasts work it's so
organic I think what you do is you film
one you find the bits and then we just
go we fill them in then we just go to
your we just know we're going we're
starting here and we're ending there and
also I don't winner of but I did this
notice we're up to 244 likes which is
incredible but but right now all we need
to do is even people are going wow
that's amazing or they're going they're
saying that although now look at
yourself in the mirror say now it's
amazing send us a clip whatever put it
what if when you did this everybody that
was watching look like they're in front
of a mirror like you wasted your Genie
power half if I'm doing if I have Genie
powers and I'm doing it for whatever
bits on a podcast that I'm ways to the
mainland but I can see you there GE you
get you fight a genie that he's like
what's your first wish your first wish
is firing all my edits anytime I do this
I could do and be like can I just give
you a billion dollars so listen man it's
easy we just take what we have now all
we need to do is you look for the my
t-shirt you put the t-shirt on I [ __ ] in
the bushes a couple of times we go to my
house we film this whole thing
word-for-word there we slice it up you
get Charlotte Lawrence to come over and
sit here
for a second and get me a nicer muscle
well I actually do have a lot of time
before this episode is gonna come out so
I made a light a clog I literally could
go to your house in the next whatever a
few days and if we wanted to fix it up
we could there was some one you guys
were seeing us talk about it and it
never happened yeah it did happen but he
didn't put it in don't make me have to
be the person that's already gonna do it
you're the bad guy you have like
something you can put on like a shofar
costume or something sorry I did that to
you dude but you walked into that oh my
god you know it's great we're making
bits out of snaps without having to do
the out of it yeah this is fun this is
Morgan's or snap pitches that's perfect
I got to go to the bathroom I'll be
right back oh my god I can't wait to do
this to you nothing makes me pee more
than a good bit so thank you so much you
guys while I'm gone Eric's gonna be
talking but feel free to just put the
screen on minimum whatever it is output
over to reclassify comm and pick up one
of these take your shoes off yeah this
is what happens when you you have Rick
Glassman in your life I don't want to
plug them all right I've plugged them
before do you want a box you know what
because of your podcast
they sent me boxes and boxes of this
look under the sink in that bathroom
right there that's that's uh you can
grab one of those boxes
anyways so as you can see it's a
nightmare heavy Rick Glassman on the
podcast he's out you know he literally
got up and went to go to the bathroom in
the middle of it ah so maybe I'll just
like do it edit of like hello yeah [ __ ]
I have a pitch for you why don't you put
those back on because you're the only on
the complaint so I want to on when you
come back on my
Podcast I want to do a bit were sit on
the couch and I snap and we're here
uh-huh
so I just want to film that part here
and you could leave it in this podcast
we were already up to 322 likes it's
incredible so we could film it on this
podcast but I'm gonna put that in mind
so when you come on we got to wear this
outfit what it's a joke on a joke if we
snap with notifications and outfits
right so I want to be at my place and I
want to be like my phone at your spot
okay snap we're gonna come back here and
you're gonna be like did you find it all
right here we go
all right so we just coming out remember
guys we're just coming from we're at my
place I can't find my phone we're
looking for it all right make sure you
press subscribe and click the bell one
of those like telephones for your
[ __ ] podcast we're gonna take your
shoes off telethon you ready I'm so I
got it what do you got it if you got it
leave a comment and say you get it you
can't wait to think you could say Happy
New Year after the first week of January
which while making fun of that was me
and my intro on monday's episode with
Adam right all right we're just coming
out for my place I'm looking for my
phone mm-hmm first of all let's cut on
that don't do that don't do what no I
think you should just I think you should
just be looking you know like you like
you just arrived okay hey Eric cuz that
little you know know know what that's
terrible I hear you that the moisture my
teleportation land terrible we see yours
your teleportation landing I'm just here
you're not doing one no yeah see that's
I've arrived yeah well
such a thing that either one of us would
say this I don't think either of us
would say when we get to a party or
something I've arrived have arrived yeah
I hear you
I appreciate the note but I'm in a knife
also said that you should move the chair
so then we don't have to worry about it
like it is if like you know we've come
into like Oh see I just did there's my
teleportation landing ah yeah that's
right you do but yours or whatever that
was I wouldn't mind doing another
teleportation which is where ATT comes
from because their teleporting sound
waves God okay I'm gonna choke from
other love this is the best time I've
had enough on my own podcast laughing it
the nonsense I've arrived I've arrived
you did it how you said it is how you
supposed to do the teleportation landing
it doesn't everything doesn't not
everything has to be big mm-hmm yeah
Rick have you found your phone yes I
have people are commenting in my podcast
now why isn't it bigger
[Laughter]
right now there's gonna be a poll up
about history a little circle click that
for you know the poll of our Rick's
teleportation bit
give me the options the options gonna be
big or small I got a dude like you know
like on a scale when we'll film a few
takes
okay teleportation landing a alright so
I'm gonna go smaller to bigger okay good
okay yeah all right you gonna go yeah
that was a teleportation landing a
teleportation I didn't do
how many do in three four four okay no
three is good three said be
teleportation landing
should have gone up like a big morning
well you didn't let me say Rick have you
found your phone because remember we're
looking for the phone you're already did
you are you already have ruined the
whole it's okay you know
another ATT but do we have to do is what
we would use I don't know coop from the
looks of the polls it's not doing too
well by the way I keep making this joke
if we are legit under a hundred fifty
likes right now I'm not coming over
anymore
okay get this up into those lights guys
all right yeah yeah okay go we're doing
B again yeah ready yeah
so Rick you find your phone yes I mean
so many missed calls boring yeah where
you see that was boring okay so now this
is gonna be for this to make sense
I'm not can't be the only one who's
affected by the teleportation so you got
a murder numbers no cuz you don't really
realize that the Edit right now it was
just you on this you know I was coming
over I know but on my podcast is nobody
watching yours mine no you're gonna get
the footage of both of us watching your
version of these edits are like reading
the script Iron Man 9 is like watching
an IMAX oh god yeah in German it's not
perfect but the Germans think it's
hysterical it's over this one
this teleportation was uh yeah this
teleportation just for a little prep
yeah yeah that's a big one and we have
to we have to respond this is the first
time I've done it before but I haven't
got used to this is the first time
you've ever done it so for a second you
forgot why we're like holy Joe don't
tell me how to do my teleportation
landing okay okay well I'm directing my
podcast somebody's got to know if this
remind there'd be [ __ ] all the
bushes by now
all right you ready I'm ready
okay uh you guys everybody at home so we
can hear from there as long as you can
yell three right it'll be three - I
won't say one and then we'll do it okay
three two if anybody still watches you
gotta press like to move your chair up
so you don't mess up my brick you write
it off all right we'll do that again you
ready I'm ready three two
hmm
where's your phone Rick seems like the
teleportation changed your voice yeah
all right now getting annoyed because
they're doing bits on bits and these
aren't good let me just do the real one
all right I'll take whatever my
responsibility is for the past five
minutes I'm sorry but keep watching and
subscribe all right just I'm gonna
teleport okay you know and I'll lean
back a little yeah all I've ever right
and then ask I'm gonna look for it for a
second you say check tell me to check
you know whatever over directing on this
is crazy you should have seen him on the
set of Iron Man uh I was trying to think
of how to say something in German and
okay three two now I'm out I'm not even
joking I'm legit insecure
so but that could be the number three
choice right there guys is the first one
send me the first one in this one one
more this one all right and I take all
of this out you know I'll do it for you
you put it wide real fast
[Laughter]
what here's what here's what it is I got
it we're still going so I'm legitimately
hot sweating aware and sorry but I
really want to get this form up for that
episode when you come out of me
I'm sorry I really am I know I know this
is so for this it would be fun it's
Europe I'm sure you could play this
pretty well you're annoyed with me at my
house probably by this point yeah of
course so if you be on your phone annoy
to me and when we teleport you're still
on your phone looking at it you're
you're not bothered by it right and
we're on your just get these likes up to
30 on Rick's podcast all right so I'm on
the so I'm gonna be on the phone on your
part you're on the phone my podcast
phone in the left hand you're wearing
what you're wearing
you gotta keep that fascia layer the
same and I will just take it from here
all right we're coming up for my place
where's my phone I think I left my phone
at your house and I'm just getting into
character okay found it yes so many
missed calls
all right great I was basically just but
I got to get into character for when I
met your voice but we went the reason
why we laughed yes yes this is just the
most bizarre of the my podcast with you
it's always bizarre but I do want to do
you did give a good idea to me about
what we should do we could probably do
it on another episode is that we're
gonna read each other's comments
right I like I I'm reading the comments
on your episode and vice versa yeah yeah
yeah
do that we got a lot we got some ideas
I'm gonna leave some comments now
sincerely this time so when you have my
mind we could look at some well look at
them and see what people all mean about
me I get it but throw some nice ones out
there so I could be like well this
person said Rick made me say he has a
cool sweatshirt
but I could get it Rick Glassman calm or
whatever yeah the great price is that
marshall's rug you know what I would
like to do I would like to offer a
special promo code specifically from
this so I could see if I sell even one
sweatshirt wow that's a good I wish I
make the promo code for this I'll have
it when this comes up I'll have it up
for the for the first week this should
be the teleportation landing I can't
spell teleport teleport too long hashtag
teleport Griffin easy I believe that's
the same amount of letters P yeah what
go ahead
Grif f r RI f fi n @ 6 RI f fi ennas 6
spell teleportation no I said teleport
spell it you'll spell it I don't know
how and that's the problem tele2 RT
piece of [ __ ] 2 more 6 8 te le P ort oh
so you said TL o go to Rick Glassman the
comm link eric is gonna put a link in
the in the description and use that use
promo code and also make sure you put a
promo code colon riffin so I put a
picture of a colon over you snap and now
we're dressed you're a circle and I'm a
comma or a colon hoodie for get a
discount and I want to see if I could
sell one sweatshirt unless god what time
I think we don't know how long we've
gone it feels like it's been three hours
if you make all the proper we started
thicket at 45 okay okay okay so yeah we
haven't yeah it just feels like forever
my girlfriend
I had a missed call she said let me set
this up beforehand I don't think I said
on here so Eric people know about your
twitch thing yeah right so no it's on
Instagram you say why I on YouTube on
youth Eric Griffin gaming I game on my
other channel Eric Griffin gaming and
and he I get music these things during
it I stay in raft it's a full screen of
the game sometimes he's not even playing
the game it's just the character waiting
for it Eric is is a complete concert you
know 40 years old 50 years old maybe by
the time this is edited 55 there so
funny and you know what I'm gonna do you
a favor we're gonna cut to a clip and so
I'm looking through it on Instagram at
like 1:30 in the morning and I see you
have to show a clip of it so people who
if they don't see what it is or just or
just know it's gonna it's right here
it's already or just make one really
slow you're talking it's covered you
already don't even see you right now I
get it very very poetic cuz you haven't
seen me since I got here now I'm just
like your parents so so I'm a black I
don't know if I get it but I don't have
any go attached to it so I'm just gonna
say funny stuff I'm laughing in bed at
just and you sound good you sound good
you know you're what did you say call of
duty call a booty I think it on the
booty with the cootie never stop yeah it
was you know a little not as good as
that but like something like that and
I'm laughing and then uh uh Betty woke
up and I showed her and she laughed and
then she went I don't even know she
really woke up she's so fine your
can't wait for you to have assisted
masturbation had me in a few hours so
our sex is so magical
don't hurt me a little bit because we do
have it is really we're both real good
at it you know and together it's magic
ah okay so move I leave and magic and
then I cut to like that that hidden
camera in your room no you don't use it
a blackout like it's showing your
butthole because she's on top you know I
mean your bottles already blacked out
oh yeah you're not gonna put it of
course not of course you sent me edited
footage during during it there's give me
my sweatshirt across her nipples are
blurred by my merchandise but for you I
make you like a potato head yeah it's
like a watermark like I know this is the
one I gave Eric so it's not yeah yeah
people sometimes tell me like oh you
laugh too much this kind of stuff if I'm
laughing is because I'm legitimately
filled with mirth no because sometimes I
will use the word mirth after Christmas
no this is why be edited except
Christmas welcome to the Christmas
episode why don't we cut to our
Christmas episode of our snowball fight
ah so anyways I laugh only I only laugh
when I really enjoy something and I've
left a lot on this podcast and it's
because of Rick Glassman so so click
that like yeah Wow if anybody's a [ __ ]
yeah what are they gonna do like so
anyways so then Betty goes asleep and
she woke up like five minutes later
laughing and I thought I knew why she
was laughing but I asked and she said
I'm just Eric his little head in there
and then we and we both just for like a
minute probably a minute just laughing
at it so much anyway I called her to
blah blah blah blah earlier on I don't
know if you dumped it in and she messes
me and she said I had to break from yoga
because
laughing thinking about where you were
and Eric's rapping it's getting up a
part of that relationship so funny now
cut to the you two in bed just like
laughing during sex and then starting to
think like why are we thinking about
Eric right now all right cut back and
I'll tell you why because you set it up
and I'm gonna knock it down for real
some nice comments because I know how
exhausting this you spend well people
love me do they take your shoes off is
blowing up it's a no it's gonna be a
huge podcast by the end of 2020 and if
you don't believe me let's fast-forward
so the reaction that is not big another
reaction of like watch gold chain 20
minutes I know you're filled with mirth
but we gotta go no it's your assistant
with tons of gold change still another
Jew I'm wearing Rick's go change he
couldn't get here oh man I am having a
really good I have to film I'm filming
one of my podcasts now today at 4:00 who
you got coming up Josh Peck do you know
who that is very funny to throw Drake
and Josh no no from do you guys know
that one even though I'm filming it now
that it probably came out nine months
ago by the time this is all so so go
check it out over the episode 40
something but he's coming over and I'd
like I've used my energy for the week
yeah this is it for you
you're not even gonna snap you're gonna
be doing one finger snaps with him
uh-huh
you every like just does this give me
because I'm gonna beg him to do beat
poetry and I'm gonna step along and
every time it snaps when he leaves I'm
gonna do pickup I'm just gonna switch
sweatshirts but wait but you're not
gonna put them on you're just gonna lay
them on your body entire just put them
on Rick I'm gonna end up cg eyeing them
on it's gonna take so long you get to
spend like a hundred thousand dollars to
make that one episode better but the
podcast is doing real well now yeah
people talk about it I was doing
oh but thanks huh yeah I think the
podcast is but just what's your part do
you do you think you have to have guests
every time so I recorded a solo episode
the other day did it feel weird to you I
can see it being weird - yeah because in
an and I know why I think it's weird to
you because it's like if you're just
doing all this stuff by yourself you
know what I do you know like yeah but
then you have no one to like I like to
fight off the energy of annoyance or
even happiness or even whatever usually
that ii yeah so you don't you need that
so what do you do when you don't have it
yeah so so my I started doing intros now
and that some of them I go a little
longer to kind of like practice some so
somewhere like seven to eight minutes
Jesus wait that long yeah um it's like a
solo episode yeah but it's I don't I
don't have to carry it for too long and
and I do like them but yeah I don't know
I like to play I like no but you can
still do all that playing that's why
that's why I'm trying these intros you
don't do any chores right no not even
for the iTunes versions no because I
have the thing about my music starts the
intros it's like I'm filming another
mini episode every week is this I dunno
there I know they're over produced
there's an example of one now as my name
is request I would really do was on the
screen I was just doing that in case you
weren't really gonna do it you know it's
funny as I probably could we could
actually just do that all we gotta do is
to you know you take a picture you just
superimpose it you know I want to end my
podcast when you come on the one that we
come over where we I find my phone I
want to end it where we're teeing up and
I'm gonna come back on yours so let's
just go there now did we get the way the
same thing again let's do this let's go
there now I don't know if I want to wear
the same thing I might do a special snap
close snap it's a double snap but yeah
when we end yours I want to treat it
like the end of mine as well so whenever
we're ending and what is that just
however we ended I want to treat it as
if we just came back from my living room
oh jeez I can't even now I'm so like I
can't even keep track of what Adam
I got him yeah it's uh pretty I'm
exhausted now I know I feel it I mean I
just I know you are exhausting how does
Betty deal with it
I must exhaust a [ __ ] I like with Betty
uh-huh isn't a podcast no but well no no
okay hear what you're saying it and I
know this my intro for the Adam Ray 2.0
one that came out yesterday whenever for
you I almost didn't post it we got so
high it's so funny but I didn't even
watch it that when I couldn't edit right
I was so embarrassed by myself I got
behavior sincerely because I'm and I and
I put it in the intro that's what I said
I almost didn't post this but this part
of me that I'm about to show is
sincerely a part of me that I have [ __ ]
I'm embarrassed about a part of me that
like I've worked really hard to not be
anymore see I feel like now I need to
record an intro of this episode do it at
my place the most ridiculous waste of
time and resources you should grow if
you're switch your huge mustache with a
thing on your lip so it's do I have a
Hitler here and then I have a yes and no
no hear what he does to me what happens
is the snap is a little broken doesn't
work so you now have to drive home and
the podcast is in the car let's get back
no actually not a terrible idea is to
drive you know and then how I can easily
bring to Zune and we can I've thought
about I have a
go pro yeah well you got to get you to
get a feel dude I I want to just need
one guy dude I am exhausted I do want to
touch on that though what if I want to
finish what you're saying about your
life with with Betty but Betty so wow
that's such an old-school name to know
I've met Betty in a long time yeah she's
gonna be a great grandma's real yeah
I've met her she was I I didn't think
she was real but she came yeah I have a
girlfriend she lives in London you
haven't met her she's real miss teracle
I don't exhaust her trust me she's real
that's why she doesn't London cut to her
and London in there in our place three
of us there be like oh [ __ ] a show great
trip no I left my passport but you don't
need it so there's something about by
the way just before you could continue
with that part of me like the next time
you come on part of me wants to have
instead of this I literally just have a
green screen and then like this I could
just put whatever I want sure you know
to me it's like oh it'd be great to do a
green screen yeah I usually can do that
gives get it there and put it down where
it comes up and down and then or not
what I didn't no need to do I need that
for my gaming I would just get another
one that I could roll down a roll back
up yeah
just for when I'm on yeah you even have
a little practical take your shoes off
logo on the right I'll pay for it so
this is like an advertisement weird like
behind the scenes yeah well sometimes
you gotta find I asked for example put
in Marshall Roy gallery how do I make
money I'm not making any money off this
and nobody's buying [ __ ] rugs from it
it's just I like that really owns a rug
yeah it's a it's Marshall Marshall
Marshall flooring and tiles Marshall won
but he in his hook is a ship and his
partners do carpet in Thailand he does
the rug Oh gotcha gotcha gotcha
and my spy pockets call take your shoes
off I have I have the nicest rugs any
one-bedroom apartment has literally
thousands of dollars these rugs a piece
in my cost you
they're so nice and not if you want to
check them out go to Marshall rug you
know now you're gonna take your shoes
off I should sell sweatshirts and write
really expensive rug yeah
anyway this energy that I'm having with
you that you know that I know and and I
like a lot of the time right it's a lot
it's a lot I'm I have been able to in
these past you know we've talked about
the last play podcast in the past few
years is I've been able to control it
better and I'm not perfect
all right but when I'm here I have so
much I love this I have so much fun in
your pot yeah I get it
I just you know I know how to drive the
speed limit this is actually probably
better for her that you're coming on
here like like having a dog go run
around at the park all day yeah yeah but
yes that's gonna be like key go to
Eric's market like I'm gonna be like I'm
not even really recording
I'm just for her but I haven't just used
the day I've used I mean I'll be back at
the end of the month like with energy
you know I've just depleted myself I
know I ran out energy so I said give me
some of your life oh god man but also
uh-huh as honest as it is it's like yes
this is exhausting and bits are
exhausting yes in my head the way I work
we just keep the stuff that works you
know what I'm saying you know what I'm
saying cuz there's so much funny stuff
there's so much funny we laugh so much
in this episode you know but we're also
gonna see all the time that I'm begging
you to [ __ ] in a bush you know but yeah
there's something there's certain people
that then then I go I'm putting my foot
on the pedal you know I mean because
with you when it doesn't work it's funny
it's funny examine it works it's funny
unfortunately um you're welcome tell you
what we'll put up all your dates right
here oh my god yeah what's a good idea
actually
how is this going for real what am I
being is this is this is it because no I
think it's great I don't really ask
about I was asked that's why I was
asking about Betty it was interesting to
meet her she's very nice
you know I
to turn it on and and I guess just for
better or worse I'm turning it on right
now
yeah or you know in and I guess I you
know what it is because it's a safe
space so that's what it really is
so you're welcome for that - no I'm
tired because I didn't I reach in again
yeah you like a good mustache but that
but that's still you editing that's self
editing right there that's an no joke
that's what I've been working on the
past few years for real when do you snap
and commit and when do you just pitch it
yeah
well this this what this episode is
gonna be called you can just snap ish
yes yeah snap pitch I think for the last
two minutes why don't we just be silent
just so you get edited some silence yeah
it is all like you know they're just
like I just show clips it's like a like
the end of a basketball game you know of
the Olympics and then they play the
Whitney Houston one moment in time you
know they decided they show quite light
highlights from the podcast I just do
them in slow-mo we should only have this
one okay okay I don't know why I do you
think it's gonna be good or is you I
don't have to pitch it
no I'll pitch it sing that how do we
know what you're gonna pitch sing that
for 20 seconds uh-huh we did this on
mine with a fan you'll sing that for 20
seconds you just do to Benny Hill one
moment I'm works better for this okay
and sing that and instead of you having
to find the best moments of this podcast
we're going to pick some just we make
them right here and this and so just
sing now and we're not gonna use the
video of you singing if you will but
just you know I'll do some stuff
don't move it no it's not the end no you
don't need to get the bushing frame okay
we end with a montage doesn't include
this is gonna mess up my whole thing
that's the difference yeah thank you
guys so much for tuning and riffing with
Griffin my name's Rick Glassman you can
check me out to take your shoes off
podcast at Rick Glassman on instagram at
shoes off pod on Instagram shoes off pop
why don't you do why did you just get
take your shoes off Instagram I don't
know maybe was too long okay but anyways
I do want to thank Rick Glassman for
coming on my really honestly
legitimately good friend thank you and I
had like I'm exhausted right now
we'll keep it right we're gonna have to
do another ending after this for my
episode oh Jesus quite once you say it
together
oh my god yeah what is it what's that
ending okay so you're gonna be at my
place I'm gonna teleport it over we okay
we just like with the phones or what do
we we know each other or litter or that
foam bit okay now I went back we went
back back again now we continued the
podcast we talked about you know you and
right you know what it's whatever
yeah well it's like being on Showtime or
who gives a [ __ ] it's like now when
we're closing it out be like all right I
wanna yeah it's gonna be like all right
asked me to come back you're gonna ask
me to come back on your podcast I'll say
let's just do it now we'll just close
out at your place and then wait what
all right we're at my or at my house
okay we're doing the podcast uh-huh
we're about to end and you're gonna say
to me Rick I want you to come back on do
riff from the Griffin okay I say that
there yeah and I'll say let's just do it
now
all right and then you'll say don't we
need an ending to your podcast and I'll
say we'll just do it at your place you
don't say and now we're gonna cut back
here so end and take your shoes off
uh-huh
and my episode you will do it you do it
[Music]
I'm tired [ __ ] you I'm tired
Willie's do attack and there's another
poll up right now who had the better
ending take it alive Paul's as big as a
pole oh yeah it looks like this callback
all right you want me to enter you and
exhaust it and then we have to do this
though we have to end my podcast as it
goes into yours so I'm gonna end it
thank you so much and then you're gonna
welcome and then do the beginning of
your podcast and that's how I'm gonna
end mine that make sense okay great
we're gonna come back once I'm done I'm
gonna say goodnight and then start your
figures ready that's fine it'll be good
from what I mean it's fine I'll put the
headphones on once we start yours we'll
both do that you know I mean no we're
switching over right so here's how we
have to do it no but I can have mine on
Eric we I have to I have to end a
podcast it's gonna be on my episode bye
that's your mistake we're gonna head my
podcast so I'm gonna mean your chair I'm
gonna say goodnight we're gonna switch
and you're gonna start start yours what
are you trying to take it back no yes
too many I agree
all right we're coming back no I'm gonna
end my podcast and you're gonna go rest
that would be a lot funnier if they did
this if they just you know its
proprietary about my comedy but if you
want to just take everything I have oh
no never mind it's what happens after
the snow added me to be like okay now we
have to do three takes because I don't
know what's teleportation take we use
all right so we just so we just left so
another ATT you're asking me you asked
me to come on your podcast I said let's
just do it now you said right now it's
just credit what about an ending D
thanks for coming thanks for watching
Eric Griffin thanks for watching Griffin
with Griffin if you want to see this fun
thing play out
check out take your shoes off it blah
blah blah suck my [ __ ] alright alright
Oh three two whoa thank you so much for
tuning in to take your shoes off podcast
with special guest Erik Griffin I'm Rick
Glassman thank you
all right thanks for uh doesn't say
coming over but thanks thanks for doing
this
yeah all right ready I want to have you
on again the beginning of my podcast
are you ready are you gonna count us in
20 1980 ladies and gentlemen once again
now thank you for watching your favorite
podcast you know tonight
[Music]
I know this is how the brilliance works
you can stop we got it we're done you
want to keep this fight but then they're
seen inside baseball thanks once again
for watching river with Griffin and
please subscribe and share check out
Rick's podcast on take your shoes off
I'll be using this this right now so
thank you very much everybody glasses
and everybody Eric Griffin pitching
[Music]
[Applause]
goodbye everybody
you